you may think this is a traffic jam but
these lines are caused by a shortage of
fuel in idlib the most densely populated
city in Northwest Syria
Ahmed like many others here use a
motorbike to get around he was only able
to buy one liter of fuel and it cost him
two dollars a price considered high in
the area
this much won't even get me from home to
work fuel is only available through the
local Council you must register and
there is a long list if it goes on like
this you won't be able to feed our
families
the Salvation government of idlib
founded by a former Al-Qaeda affiliate
has imposed taxes and limited Fuel and
sugar sales
the local government is to blame for the
shortest because it is not importing
enough fuel the black market is selled
to the people at three times the normal
price can you believe that we burn shoes
sometimes we are fed up with our lives
at least 4 million live in idlib most
have flood their homes in other
provinces nearly half the population
lives in refugee camps and depends on
humanitarian Aid to survive
I've been burning firewood for the past
two months I couldn't even fill my gas
cylinder because I can't afford it I
wish I could live like a human being the
plunging currency in turkey has spilled
over into the city which adapted the
Turkish lira more than two years ago
while the world is focused on the
humanitarian crisis caused by the war in
Ukraine syrians are battling with
International funding shortfalls they're
hoping that donors and governments will
remember their commitments in this
12-year War SI Namco solo altazira